[Música]
el órgano más grande de tu cuerpo no es
tu hígado o tu cerebro es tu piel con
una superficie de unos 1,86 metros
cuadrados en los adultos Aunque muchas
áreas de la piel tienen características
diferentes mucha de esta superficie
realiza funciones similares como
transpirar sentir calor y frío y hacer
crecer pelo pero luego de un corte
profundo o una herida la nueva piel se
verá diferente Y puede que no recupere
totalmente sus habilidades durante un
tiempo o en absoluto para comprender Por
qué sucede esto necesitamos mirar la
estructura de la piel humana la capa
superior la epidermis está compuesta por
células endurecidas los queratinocitos
que dan protección dado que esta capa
externa se cambia y renueva
constantemente es muy fácil repararla
pero a veces una herida penetra en la
dermis la cual contiene vasos sanguíneos
varias glándulas y terminaciones
nerviosas que permiten las muchas
funciones de la piel y cuando eso sucede
desencadena los cuatro procesos del
proceso de regeneración
la primera etapa hemostasia es la
respuesta de la piel a dos amenazas que
está perdiendo sangre y que la Barrera
física de la epidermis ha sido dañada a
medida que los vasos sanguíneos se
contraen para reducir el sangrado en un
proceso llamado vasoconstricción las
amenazas se evitan con un coágulo de
sangre una proteína especial conocida
como fibrina forma enlaces cruzados en
la superficie de la piel y evita que la
sangre fluya hacia afuera y que entre en
bacterias o patógenos luego de unas tres
horas la piel se empieza a poner roja lo
que indica la nueva etapa la inflamación
cuando el sangrado está bajo control y
la Barrera asegurada el cuerpo envía
células para luchar contra los patógenos
entre las más importantes están los
glóbulos blancos llamados macrófagos que
devoran a las bacterias y el tejido
dañado en un proceso llamado fagocitosis
además de producir factores de
crecimiento para estimular la curación
ya que estos diminutos soldados deben
trasladarse hasta el sitio los vasos
sanguíneos contraídos ahora se expanden
en un proceso llamado vasodilatación
dos o tres días después de la herida
ocurre la etapa proliferativa en que las
células fibroblastos entran en la herida
en la deposición de colágeno producen
una proteína fibrosa llamada colágeno en
la zona herida y forman tejido conectivo
para reemplazar la fibrina anterior
mientras que las células epidérmicas se
dividen para regenerar la capa externa
de la piel la dermis se contrae para
cerrar la herida finalmente en la cuarta
etapa de remodelación la herida madura
cuando el colágeno depositado se
reorganiza y se convierte en tipos
específicos mediante este proceso que
puede tomar hasta un año la resistencia
a la atracción de la piel nueva Mejora y
los vasos sanguíneos y otras conexiones
se fortalecen con el tiempo el nuevo
tejido puede alcanzar el 50 a 80% de sus
funciones originales según la gravedad
de la herida inicial y de la función en
sí misma
pero como la piel no se recupera 100%,
la cicatrización sigue siendo un
problema clínico para los médicos y a
pesar de que los investigadores han
hecho avances significativos en la
comprensión del proceso de curación
muchos Misterios permanecen sin resolver
por ejemplo los fibroblastos llegan por
los vasos sanguíneos o del tejido de la
piel adyacente a la herida y Por qué
algunos otros mamíferos como los siervos
curan sus heridas mucho más eficiente y
completamente que los seres humanos con
esas respuestas podremos algún día
sanarnos también a nosotros mismos que
las cicatrices serán algo del pasado
[Música]
nuestros cuerpos tienen mecanismos
increíbles que funcionan constantemente
para mantenernos sanos por ejemplo los
ojos sabía que los ojos producen tres
tipos de Lágrimas y que cada uno tiene
un propósito específico para ayudarlo a
mantenerse mejor descubra más con este
video